neither we are cutting out of that to
return to the secretary Anthony blinkin
who's speaking
[Music]
now in is a good place to
start we're trimed to stand against M
and what it has done and to make sure
that it can't happen again we're
determined to stand with and for
innocent civilians who suffer primarily
as a consequence of what loss is done on
all sides uh we come to work together as
well to ensure that this uh crisis this
conflict doesn't spread other places and
we come to think together about a Way
Forward uh for everyone in the region
that
is positive uh affirmative the contrary
of the vision that Hamas has which is
simply teror destruction
murder
um what we've seen out of these
last days I think makes clear that there
really are two paths for this region and
one is the path of Greater integration
normalization
collaboration uh affirmation of the
rights of
Palestinians uh and working together
common purpose common benefit that's one
path the other path is the one that's
offered by
Hamas uh a path as I said that offers
nothing but death destruction Terror
nism I think the choice is very clear
the challenge is for us to work together
to put everyone clearly affirmatively on
that first path we know that that's what
the overwhelming majority of people in
this region want uh it's certainly what
we believe
uh they need and grateful for the
opportunity to consult with you uh about
the challenges we face in the immediate
but also our have
[Music]
forward that's the US Secretary of State
Anthony blinkin saying the challenge is
for us to work together that is the
overwhelming uh requirements the
majority of the people in this region
want let's go back to Patty Khan who was
listening into that Washington DC Patty
the sound wasn't great but I think
hopefully you got an idea of what the US
Secretary of State was saying and and
pretty much as
expected yes pretty much as expected no
I couldn't really make out what he was
saying but he's been pretty much saying
the same thing at every one of these
stops really trying to bring back to the
Forefront what happened in Israel
talking much less about what is
happening currently in Gaza uh again
interestingly he's was really just
scheduled to come at the beginning they
told the reporters here in Washington
he's going to Israel then he's going to
Jordan then they added on all these
stops then he met with the Palestinian
Authority president Mahmud Abbas then he
went to cter uh Saudi Arabia United Arab
Emirates now to Egypt now back to Israel
so that would seem to me that there's
some sort of shuttle diplomacy going on
uh but not exactly clear what go the
goal is what the aim is the one thing
that the US has not talked about at all
is if there are any limits for this
operation into Gaza uh but again one of
the interesting things is we are now
starting to hear from National Security
adviser Jake Sullivan very publicly
saying that Israel needs to respect the
ab gaza's people in gaza's ability to
get clean water food electricity that is
the very first time they have put any of
the onus on Israel uh they've been
saying just in the last couple of days
humanitarian Aid become became an issue
uh saying that uh they want to get
humanitarian Aid in and they seem to
imply that that should come from Egypt
so could be seen interesting pivot uh
again couldn't really make out what's
going on with uh an what Anthony blinkin
was saying very unusual for the White
House Press pool feed to be that bad uh
but hopefully they'll refeed it and
we'll be able to actually uh hear what
he had to say yep I think you summed it
up pretty well there from what we heard
Patty thanks for that back with you a
bit later thank you Patty